[Music]
i am obsessed with collecting
african-american history and it is my
enjoyment it soothes my soul
it's described as one of the most
important collections of
african-american history ever assembled
but it's not found in any museum it's
housed in the staten island new york
home of 90-year-old elizabeth meters for
the past 60 years this former new york
city school teacher has been assembling
artifacts that document the entirety of
the african-american experience from the
nation's beginning to the current day
this is a display of abolition and
slavery telling stories filled with
tears and triumphs with one mission in
mind my mission in collecting this
this particular african-american history
collection
is
to create a patriotic healing and
teaching instrument
to compensate for the fact that as a
teacher and just as an ordinary citizen
i know that african-american history has
been completely omitted from american
history meters african-american history
trust collection features over 20 000
individual items and over here we have
an authentic
baton
that belonged to cab calloway
[Music]
here's a autographed picture of him with
his baton making great music there are
personal letters from historic icons
this is a martin luther king signed
civil rights letter and memorabilia from
the world of sports over here we have a
life-size wax figure that came out of a
wax museum of hank aaron an important
iconic african-american sports hero in
this corner we have a bronze statue of
joe lewis and on the bottom a pair of
muhammad ali's fight one shoes the items
fill every nook and cranny of meters
home and that's not an exaggeration
but as she enters her 90s meters made
the tough decision to part ways with her
collection by putting it up for auction
not as individual pieces but sold intact
you know even collectors reached the end
of the road and when you're as old as i
now am it's important to take on the
responsibility of making sure that it
has another life elizabeth meter's
collection is nothing short of
extraordinary arlen ettinger is the
president of guernsey's auction house i
hadn't seen anything like before nor
have i seen anything like it since
a collection that
comprehensively
documents the african-american
experience in ways that much smarter
people than i much more knowledgeable
people than i think is the finest
collection of its type in existence so
it's overwhelming over here i have
weaponry from the civil war
estimates of the collection's value vary
but it could be worth as much as 10
million dollars i'm shocked to know that
a pokemon card can go for million
dollars and that
marilyn monroe's dress can go for five
million dollars
and so my question really is how much
does america value american history i
have no idea
and
i have only a prayer that i send out
with this collection
and you know meters obviously wants to
keep it intact that auction is going to
start next month at guernsey guernsey's
really interesting she took odd jobs to
finance this mortgaged her house a few
times and it started with admiration for
jackie robinson and it just inspired her
to keep going it's and it's amazing how
much she's focused on the next
generation and making sure all of this
stuff ends up in the right hands and for
all to see let's hope yeah i'm surprised
she didn't have a second life as a
curator
i'm sure this is not gonna adore
uh